welcome to this video round six of the
candidates tournament and this video is
about the game Mammadyarov with white
against Peter Svidler money manager of
us on- one he was really starting badly
but has bounced back with a win and
smith also won yesterday so on he's on
+1 again so in a good situation after he
beat the ball off let's see what happens
here Mammadyarov is playing deform it
seems that mean this is this is normal
move but once in a while he plays efore
or others and it seems that he
consistently is playing d4 in this
tournament yeah it's witless playing the
gruene fat or not nope playing the Dutch
defense which is really a bit of a
shocker speedla really am is um so yeah
reliably plagued the gruene thought you
almost feel like there is some sort of
yeah transmission failure if there's
anything else that the groom thought but
he really has prepared the dutch it
seems as least as a surprise weapon and
he's playing it here against Mammadyarov
very interesting choice i mean this is a
surprise weapon that really feels like
he wants to win the game I mean it's a
complicated and double-edged opening
yeah Mammadyarov playing g3 night at six
yeah well they put in this on the board
rather quickly and we have the absolute
main line we can maybe put the screen
move back main position of the Leningrad
Dutch on the if the Dutch is played on
the top level it's almost always the
Leningrad it has the best reputation I
guess among the various Dutch lines it's
a really an interesting opening that
leads to very unbalanced and shower play
and therefore it's very much suited for
player with a black
who wants to wants to fight and maybe
win the game so interesting to see what
mama dr office is doing being surprised
by that but here its blackest move and
black him he has an important choice to
make um hospitaller plays Queen to e8
which for the most part of the last
let's say 25 years has been the main
move it was not one of the main moves
before that but then her Ukrainian
player Vladimir Milan yoke sorry my
voice is failing me a bit and Milan yoke
played it I don't know how often a
dozens of times with lots of success he
even um held him I believe he played
Ross oh you scalp often Kasparov I mean
he really had excellent results with the
opening and the Queen e8 took over as
the main line and only in recent years
I'm the movie 6 which has been the old
main line before this and has somewhat
come back into them into the to the
attention um it's this has some points
because the Queen at some stage can you
go to a five for example after this
Queen a five is a very decent move um
but realize playing Queen to e8 I can
recommend both moves I mean they're both
interesting I have to get my personal
perspective into that a couple of years
ago um couple of years I don't know
about 10 years ago let's say I was
playing the Leningrad touch this black
sometimes and it was interesting you
always got the kind of unbalanced
position that you like if you want to
win a game but I sort of yeah yeah I
switched to two other things and as it
has it happened so i gave up the opening
for no particular reason
I wasn't dissatisfied with what happened
but it's a it's a really good
theoretical condition I believe at the
moment okay what's mama dr offer doing
against it he plays a move before and I
really had to look it up in the database
this is really obscure move it's very
very rarely played that idea to play
before again the Leningrad some it's
actually rather normal but normally if
white tries to go for this idea he plays
before before he develops the night for
example here or even earlier earlier
it's probably a more precise but the
reason is normally in a position like
that you want to have this option to get
the night only to d2 and let's say queen
here so that the bishop is actually
working along the diagonal and not
blocked by the night so this is a very
uncommon line this be for him yes well
as playing 'if I've of course this is
the main idea of all this Queenie ate it
took played Bishop a three yeah why does
developing the queenside quickly and
this is obviously intending to play b4
b5 but an important thing is that now
Blackie gets in the movie 5 b-4 and that
there's a general rule of thumb in the
learning rate if you get the pawn to e4
without being on directly punished
punished by some sort of technical thing
arm or some sort of direct refutation
then you should do it and as well as
playing it note that both players are
investing time they are not playing on
preparation or anything they just play a
game here right from let's say move 9
yeah a four-night deform pretty
self-explanatory and now he played rook
f7 Rooke f7 is a normal move
actually in the in the Leningrad Dutch
to go to d7 that looks a bit weird but
the rook can do a good job on this
happen pinning on them on the D file and
of course white was always intending to
get something going with B 5 so this is
not a balanced black I'm actually had an
alternative he could have played Queen
to have seven this is actually the
computer suggestion and I do like it the
queen is also not bad at all on f7
especially after the pawn is on your
phone there's no Knight harassing it so
queen is just taking on luck their queen
is just attacking this pawn on c4 and
yeah this is something that white needs
to consider is black really tried to
take them yeah in some lines he may be
is but the queen is also nicely
positioned there for another idea if
white is for example covering c4 with
queen bee three and there is 96 simply
attacking this and if white captures and
now it looks a bit ugly but why it's not
able to attack the pawns quickly and
black is coming with Bishop to e6 and
this is looking very solid for black
keys attacking c4 and it seems to be
that black is in good shape I mean
certainly something that Sevilla could
have played I'm not saying it is much
better than Luke f7 or anything but it
was a good alternative the computer
actually believes that after Queen SF
black is better but I'm not so sure
about that it certainly would have been
interesting to to try but this is not a
bad news queen bee three anyway and now
96 this was villas idea to get the
knight on c6 developed exchange the
strong d4 Knight and not for the moment
on spoil the pawn structure to be five
he just went back and it certainly looks
like a decent position black can go
Bishop e6 anyway to put
pressure on this likely weekend to see
for pond and another very important
feature of courses that black with the
spawn only form is at the moment really
limiting whites bishop the g2 bishop is
not an exceptionally good piece so what
is white Sun best idea here I think that
Mammadyarov played the most principled
moves he played f3 we are getting to try
to get rid of this pawn in four so that
the bishop on g2 was actually doing
something this is I believe just just
best him he could have played rugby born
for example and but it's in the long run
there's always this question of the
bishop note that black does not have
such a problem pcs got this long
diagonal the bishop on e6 will have
something to do and the night is
obviously not a bad piece as well the
night also has another idea it can go to
g45 also attacking the pond so white has
a piece that's not playing on g2
therefore f3 makes lots of sense yeah me
and I think the next couple of moves are
are not probably the only f11 possible
but they make lots of sense to me there
should be six completing development and
well this is temporarily giving up only
four but not a problem rook t1 first and
now a six initiating play on the a file
that's very logical and now white too
corny for first there and now only form
yeah you needed to take on a six first
if you if you go with this first then
let's 8x b5 and this is a very much very
much a problem yeah note that this is
looking excellent for black
you need to take first on a six just
like Mammadyarov plate and then grab the
pawn on e4 so has black just lost upon
now he doesn't he didn't if we consider
this was happening check now the trade
at first if you do a quick count Black
is upon down but he has an interesting
move now available and this is what he
played he played b5 this was as real as
idea when he initiated all that and this
gives some counter play based on the
bishop of course what cannot take me
because this is hanging this Bishop only
three and black is just intending to get
the porn back ya hear Mammadyarov
actually calculated a very very deep
line that he also stated in the press
conference I can show you the line and
this leads to an almost foster draw the
line is not this is what he played the
lines Bishop to g5 and it's quite quite
a funny continuation I should really
show it Queen takes and now g6 check
King edge eight and this is a position
to to really a you had to take a look at
two to get all kinds of technical ideas
because it's a it's really a much
sharper than it might look at first
sight Black is threatening Bishop deform
just flat-out winning the game so we
need to look at that but there also is
the issue of blacks King look at blacks
King here in the corner this can also
easily be a be a problem at some point
if you are for instance think about
ideas like Bishop b2 just for argument's
sake greene takes chat look f8 yeah
there are lots of tricks at the position
however black can take with
it's a chance check check check I know
black escapes there is no perpetual
check for white even so Bishop b2 is is
not playable move but what should why do
against the thread on deform yeah he has
a very strong move I mean very strong
that's right if it's not bleeding to to
an advantage but he can play the move
Queen to d5 this is what Mammadyarov
calculated a very nice calculating
effort if you look at this one should
like do now and can consider various
moves first needs to consider as maybe
this check Queen takes you know what can
take on c7 and now it's this threat and
this threat what is black doing now yeah
check can take here and now the fun
thing is that why it needs to play king
h3 is quite quite funny yeah if why it
takes ok black is able to stop the pawn
it's much easier to play King h3 the
spectacular move and keep this idea life
if black no takes check and we get this
position and now it's black chat needs
to check for the drove this is a
perpetual check yeah if white tries to
do that it's still a bachelor way to get
out of it very long line black can also
in this position simply recapture 1d6
but this is also a line that Momiji are
of calculated right to the end Bishop
takes d6 and go on what what is a black
supposed to do now can check give this
check
and go here for example and get is there
a way for for--why to to play play for
win here now that's an interesting when
Jeff Luc evade look at this quite funny
check check only move check check and
what will get the rook back this is what
he had calculated and came to the
conclusion that Bishop d5 is probably
leading to a forest draw yeah 22 was the
move count and 33 the end of the line so
really long calculation and he didn't
want to allow this this draw so he went
for Queen III just moving the Queen away
from this fear of the bishop and yeah an
interesting a moment now what should
should black do yeah it seems that yes
Villa had a good move and this is Quinn
d7 he somehow didn't play it I'm not
sure I didn't see all of the press
conference but it would have been
interesting to know if this was
calculated by both players the idea is
just simple play Bishop to g4 and win
the Queen um yeah it's not like a fatal
move for white white can play a queen f3
for instance and after Bishop takes he
has the interesting try Bishop b2
because black cannot take checkmate you
know and we have equal material now but
black is certainly not in any sort of
firm any sort of problem I'm not quite
sure what the best move is to be honest
um maybe something like windy 6 could be
an idea this introduces a possible check
and also covers an important square on
evade me black is perfectly okay here
what's with laplata is also not leading
to to any trouble but I believe that
after that
at least white has no fear of being
worse yeah Bishop c5 and now swidler
played Quincy ate a bit of a mysterious
move not quite sure how we need why
needed to go to c8 exactly but it does
not seem to be a big problem each form
now played by Mammadyarov yeah what does
this move doing it gives some some room
for the king possible h5 and it yeah
improves a position just just slightly
we had an interesting alternative in
rook d1 but this is a very computer ish
move I mean it has some points this move
is actually threatening something if you
consider arm black taking for example
it's a big mistake because of this
tactical shot the very air strong Ruth
black can can obviously not take check
and where is he going now if you go here
oops Bishop b5 back it's a winter white
look the one is really a strange move
the computer gives white some some
advantage after that but it's it's
really a yeah not a very human move to
play I'm not quite sure maybe there's
simply this threat which should be seven
but yeah the possible defenses maybe
this just covering the important square
cm it would have been interesting for
wide to play but ok h4 was not bad as
well and here we come to him to the
critical point really out of the game
there have been some points before where
alternatives of course we were possible
but here the game is basically decided
on exactly this move his villa came up
with the remarkable move age 6
and I really don't know what to say I
mean he spent nine minutes on it and
it's clear that he didn't just blunder
the pawn I mean why just took g6 here
and it's clear that he just didn't he
didn't just blunder the porn but he must
have calculated well I don't know what
he calculated I didn't see this part of
the press conference I maybe you should
do that later because it would certainly
be interesting to hear what yeah I think
I read something of a brain freeze and
it's not clear to me what what the point
I was supposed to be um yeah I'd played
he played Bishop to a 2d 5 which is
somewhat attacking this this bishop and
maybe now I don't know there is nothing
really connected to the move Queen h3 is
not a threat I I really don't understand
what what he calculated um yeah maybe
the press conference can can shed some
light on that but other than that it
looks like really a blunder um black
could could play other moves I mean King
h8 for example getting the King out of
some possible checks or or with the rook
go here I don't know I mean there were
many moves that not blunder porn at age
six is just giving one up I mean he has
no compensation whatsoever Bishop d5 was
played and here Mammadyarov already
could have played a Bishop f5 with a
very strong position he didn't do that
he played h5 which is also i'm keeping
keeping an advantage intact no doubt
about that but maybe Bishop f5 was was
even stronger I'm blackest with h6 gone
from maybe from about equal unclear
equal yeah its most it wasn't like a
completely boring position when nothing
happened or nothing was they going on
but it was certainly sort of a dynamic
equilibrium and TM what is just flat-out
winning there is an attack in addition
with all that the bishop which is very
strong here
and blacks king is in trouble yeah after
Bishop default our rookie one was also a
strong move but okay Bishop before it
wasn't it wasn't bad at all yeah now
still have played rookie six maybe there
was something a bit tougher because now
we get to an end game by force and this
end game is just very easily winning for
white but it's not much fun I mean he
must have been really a completely
shocked by his age six months okay
exactly six and Bishop except this is
what I was talking about this endgame
transposition black obviously must take
rook takes and rookie three yeah g7 and
king of a deity Mammadyarov finished the
game with a very very attractive-looking
move he played the move rook g5 very
very nice-looking move very visual um
yeah the point was of course if white
takes only three black captures on g7
and in this position it's not clear if
white really can win the game here's a
pawn up but its opposite colored bishops
the a porn is very useful to have but
the other pests pawn that you have is
the e porn and this is not so dangerous
in comparison to what white is getting
in the abstract what white is getting
after Luke g5 as now black hair really
does not have anything else and capture
the rook as the bishop is attacked so
black must take and then Bishop e3 and
now we see we have ant game again with
the a porn but now White has gained the
H porn has another paso and those two
they will win the game opposite colored
bishops yes or no edits just too much I
can show you a sample line I mean there
are alternatives but i just want to show
the genuine idea why pushes the pawns
forward
of course I am sorry hey Bishop Bishop
King f2 King g82 to guard him a five
Bishop see free i need to stop the a
porn and hear what can even set this
porn into motion it's got three passes
you form and at some point in the in the
near future there will be an overload
for blacks forces yeah then check the
final the final stroke with Bishop g5
now a six and now the boat both pawns
him are too much yeah and white will
promote one of the pawns it's a it's a
very important thing to remember that if
you have to pass spawns in the in the
opposite colored bishops ending and if
they are very far apart then it's very
often a win it was funny that in the in
the official live broadcast paid a
hundred years in Grand Master and Peeta
and Newton he said that he was once told
that there is a rule of thumb that if
the pawns are so far apart that you
cannot touch them with one single hand
then then it's a win very funny kind of
rule but if you think of a board young
and one in front of you enter if you're
not having like I don't know what the
hands of I know of someone who's like
yeah like a like a basketball or
something with the big hand or what you
can easily imagine that ponds that are
let's say this far apart on this far but
that this is can easily be your hand
yeah so it's a pretty visual rule that
maybe maybe quite quite helpful okay so
very important
win of course for the tournament for
mamedyarov and swidler really has an
up-and-down tournament like no other
player in the in the field after his
somewhat lucky win yesterday against two
ball off he was on top of it again with
being on +1 and now he's back to fifty
percent well Mammadyarov for him it
looked like a disaster of a tournament
he was on minus two after just just
three rounds if i'm not mistaken and now
he's back we are not mistaken he lost
against Arnold and and another game
against the Goomba chief did he lose did
she lose against Aronian I'm not not one
hundred percent positive about that but
he lost him he lost ya think a woman it
was he lost two games and then he came
back with two wins beating under 18 and
now beating swidler so he's on fifty
percent amazingly after six round and
it's not completely out of the out of
this world to think that with this kind
of run just started maybe he's able to
do even more i mean the trend is your
friend it's a flying to chess as well so
maybe this is a big big turnaround in
this in this tournament yeah i hope you
enjoyed the coverage of this game and i
hope you will be watching again when
i'll be back with round seven which will
only be on friday because of the rest
day on thursday thanks for watching